well anthony what about you what drives
you nuts about sebastian
uh that he's a hermit that he's always
isolated i want him all to myself
all the time and he won't let me have
him i just want to like
go out and do stuff together i want to
go to restaurants together i want to
i want to go fishing together i want us
to be you know besties that hang out
and he won't hang out with me because
he's so into himself
this is my favorite interview
oh my god i love it um he's trying to
get a bromance going sebastian you're
letting him down
um i mean look i'm i'm gonna start going
around i wanna
i wanna pitch anthony and i doing what
stanley tucci is doing on cnn right now
through italy i feel like he he and i
should go through europe
visiting restaurants and giving back
feedback i feel like that could be
something we could do
oh my gosh i'm with that that's
something with that
yes if you need a third wheel a fine
i'll do it
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help